The Walking Dead is back with a new time
setting in cast of characters and
scenario for our survivors with Episode
seven we see the continuation of this
arc and throughout this video I'll be
discussing episode 7 Stradivarius in
full detail there will of course be
heavy spoilers so if you haven't seen
the show yet and I highly recommend that
you come back to this video after
watching it with that out the way
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to last week we saw the
continuation of the six year time gem
that the show introduced after the
finish of Andrew Lincoln's contract yay
he can finally go be with his real
family anyway we were introduced to a
new cast of characters we saw Legolas
reunite with Aragorn and a sneak peek of
the whisperers Episode seven continues
with this with Carol trying to convince
Daryl that his son needs protection and
with him being Rambo now that he's the
best guy for the job
daryl is currently not living his
hashtag best life and resides in the
forest with a dog named dog Daryl
believes that the boy can figure things
out on his own and doesn't seem helpful
towards the two Magne and a group are
making the perilous journey to help up
with Michonne finally seeming to open up
and trust them they go back to their
former camp and discovered that walkers
have destroyed her and Michonne decides
that the perilous journey may not be in
her best interests she eventually does
come round and even gives the group back
their weapons which highlights that
maybe she's realizing they may not be
that bad at Hilltop we see our first
view of the location since the time jump
and the place has become like a paradise
we finally learn of Maggie's fate and it
appears that she's left to stay with
Georgie leaving Jesus as the leader
Jesus has been secretly mean errand for
martial arts training and the to
discover Rosita who is alone in the
wilderness after barely surviving the
herd that we saw in last week's episode
to me they are playing pretty closely to
the comics at the moment and for those
who don't know and by the way there are
huge spoilers ahead so turn off now if
you haven't read the book or don't wanna
know about Rosie as fate but Rosie as
death is a big event in the whispers arc
when alpha disguises herself as one of
Rick's people and infiltrates the
fairground in the boots she decapitate
several and puts their heads
bikes with Rosita being one of them I
really hope the character doesn't die
though because Gabriel was finally
starting to get some outlet Jada's
friendzone james daryl is later saved by
Carol son Henry and we discovered that
the former self isolation is because he
is looking for someone presumably Rick's
body Daryl decides that you will protect
Carroll's son and ride to hilltop but
this journey is short-lived when they
get asked to look to Eugene I think they
will probably find Eugene either in a
whisper Enclave or surrounded by them
which is when we'll finally learn of the
seasons big new villains but there is
potential for a lot to happen here so
what are your thoughts on the new
direction that the Walking Dead is
taking are you enjoying the new
characters and what would you like to
see before the season's end comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my breakdown of last
week's episode who are you now this is a
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
I'll see you next week take care peace
[Music]
[Music]